always been people have been taught that
they must work hard nobody told them
they must work joyfully most human
beings have crippled themselves simply
because of fear of suffering what will
happen to me is always the question I
dia every thought every emotion every
value that you have he's picked up from
somewhere and it rules you from within
he's a man whose passion spills into
everything he encountered he infects his
zest for life into all those who seek to
live their life to the fullest he's the
author of inner engineering a Yogi's
guide to joy which is a New York Times
best-selling book he's a guru and here's
my take on his top ten rules of success
volume 2 and as always guys as you're
watching the video to be here something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well also as you are writing
something down it's much more likely to
stick in your head to enjoy
you can live life with ease
not with sugar one thing is when we say
work
it's a many young people wonderful
people who getting recognized for
whatever wonderful things they have done
leaving them apart but generally work
means always been people have been
taught that they must work hard nobody
told them they must work so virtually
nobody told them their work should be an
expression of the joy or the love they
have to work hard you work hard life
will be tedious how will it work will it
be you will do something hard only
because you don't know how to do it if
you know how to do it you do it with
ease so without learning how to do
something if we try to do it without
investing enough time and perception if
life is all expression then life becomes
a big trouble not a single day passes
for me right without witnessing tears of
joy and love around me every day
somebody will be shedding tears of Lau
and joy I don't think there's a better
way to live in this world and all of us
should strive to create our own circles
of joyfulness and pleasantness around us
because if you are not joyful by your
own nature if you are always going
around with the fear of suffering as
long as fear of suffering is there
within you you will never walk your life
with full stride it'll always be half a
step most human beings have crippled
themselves simply because of fear of
suffering what will happen to me is
always the question whatever happens
this is how I will be if this assurance
comes to you only now you will want to
scale the peaks of life and see what
about it
if it happens makes no difference to you
if it doesn't happen make no difference
to you that's when you would like to
really explore every dimension of life
so first and foremost thing is this that
your way of being is not determined by
what's around you if you bring this one
aspect to you there is no fear of
suffering once there is no fear of
suffering you will traverse the breadth
and length of this life without
hesitation when the result of an event
has no impact on you both ways you
blissed-out
you are a success when the sort of when
the fruit of the action does not
determine how you are it's just that you
do things because of the adjuvants of
what you do then you are a success the
results may depend on variety of things
thistles is not always yours results for
any result to happen whether it's in a
game or in life situations the various
factors involved not all of it is in our
control but what is in our control is
either we did our best or we did not do
our best that's in our control as long
as we're doing that and whatever the
results may be if you are still
blissed-out
that means you are a success because
life cannot defeat you anymore
dream playful always has been understood
as a responsibility
yes do you know right from your
childhood and probably to your children
also you're doing this if they're just
playful you think it's irresponsible the
most responsible way to live is that
you're playful with life
it's absolutely irresponsible to carry a
long face and walk around in this planet
yes or no isn't it absolutely
irresponsible to walk around with misery
yes that's the most irresponsible thing
you can do
so being playful is not irresponsibility
bling being playful is being very
responsible and responsive to life only
when you're playful you can do that when
you're serious the world doesn't exist
for you you and your nonsense yes when
you're serious it's just about you and
your nonsense the world and other life
does not exist for you only when you are
playful you can pay attention to
everything you can truly respond to
everything in the world only if you are
playful otherwise you cannot just the
burden of it will kill you how to convey
appear on the body on the vehicle okay
fear about whether I will be successful
or not there is a petty comment no your
individual fear about whether I will be
successful or not is that what you're
talking see that's that's exactly what I
have been telling you till now do not
even think of success just enhance you
capabilities strive to enhance who you
are then what you can do you'll anyway -
isn't it right now you have an idea of
success but you don't have the
competence for that you want to go
somewhere but you don't have the legs to
get there now naturally there will be
fear naturally there will be all kinds
of unnecessary struggles and emotions
instead that at this stage in your life
you just focus on seeing
how to enhance this human being to the
highest possible level that you can
success will be a downhill run not an
uphill task so if you are going downhill
there is no fear isn't it because
whether I can get there or not whether I
can get there or not you are working
towards somebody else's idea of success
you're working towards somebody else's
idea of success that is not success your
success is you as a human being you
found your full potential this is your
success and that's all you can do
whether you stand on your head or you
stand on your feet the best that you can
do if this human being finds is fullest
potential
that's all you can do no matter what you
do you cannot do more isn't it certain
circumstances sometimes will last it up
certain circumstances sometimes may not
but in the given circumstance if you
have blossom to your fullest level you
will do well is it it don't think of
success and be fearful about it just see
how to make this one more and more
capable the competence and capability is
there success will come as we deserve it
all human experience is generated from
within is the jump all human experience
is generated to remember them so at any
time if you feel happy or unhappy
miserable joyful ecstatic in a state of
agony doesn't matter what happens what
is your experience pleasantness or
unpleasantness just to know that it's
happening from within and it can only
happen from within you can either take
external stimuli or you can create your
own stimuli but essentially it happens
from Budin this one thing if it is not
right when you feel miserable if you
think it's this one you're gone you you
just
the keyboard is here but you're punching
the wall it is not going to work this
one basic fundamental thing is something
that almost 90% of the humanity is
always doing it wrong whenever they feel
miserable it think it must be this one
or that one or that one or that one now
all human experience is generated from
within if something is feeling
unpleasant first thing is to look at
this what am I doing wrong with this am
i eating wrong am i sleeping wrong am I
sitting wrong am i breathing wrong is my
heart beating wrong something my very
chemistry is wrong something is wrong
with this not with that so the moment
you think by kicking the wall you can
fix this one then you made a fundamental
mistake the harder you try the further
away from it you go the first thing is
to bring balance once there is balance
then you can build a tower on top of
this if there is no balance whatever you
build will only lead to more trouble the
more basic you are the better it is so
this is what a whole lot of humanity is
seeking somehow to be remain basic
because if you build something it feels
terrible when there is no fundamental
balance anything standing up without
balance is a big problem
it is number this idea of what is
success is it don't become a slave to
somebody's idea please have your own
idea you have no idea of your own don't
deceive yourself every idea every
thought every emotion every value that
you have is picked up from somewhere and
it rules you from within it rules you
from within
your religion your society your culture
has trained you to believe that this is
it so first the first and foremost
success is that you are not a slave to
anybody's idea this is sufficient to
come to the idea of mortality once in a
way it'll make you depressed it will
make you fearful if you live with it
every moment it will make you absolutely
exuberant in a life because it is just
this one thing that this is not forever
this is just for a brief period of time
and the more joyful you are briefer it
becomes if you're ecstatic it will just
vanish in no time yes so if you want to
stretch it you need to make yourself
truly miserable otherwise it'll be just
gone in no time if you come to terms
with this if you live this way that
every moment you appreciate one thing
and only one thing because the most
important thing in your life is you are
alive right now to be alive fully alive
100% alive is the most important thing
because only if something is 100% alive
can you make it eating something
beautiful a human being does not become
who he is because of his desire he
becomes who he is because of his
competence so instead of enhancing your
competence you just enhancing your
desire which will be just a horrible
burden to carry all the time you just
focus on enhancing the competence of who
this is
rather than enhancing your desire I am
going to become a world champion
everybody wants to become one they're
not going to become one isn't it
everybody wants to be successful they
will not be a success unless you do the
right things success will not happen to
you
you joke 45 minutes you gotta be serious
Joe we can yes yes okay let me tell you
[Music]
on a certain day a man fell into a
septic tank the right up till here
insult he desperately tried to come out
he could not then he started screaming
fire fire neighbors heard this call the
fire brigade five firemen came rushing
they looked all over the place no fire
then they found this man they pulled him
out and then they asked why would you
screaming fire where is the fire the man
retorted if I said [ __ ] [ __ ] would you
come over to do the right thing other
way the right things will not happen to
you
just because you have a big desire
you're not going to get there you got to
do the right thing various situations in
your life either you can use it to make
yourself stronger and better or you can
sit and cry this is the chance you have
everything it doesn't matter what
happens the most horrific event happened
in your life that also can be used for
your growth and your well-being if only
if you have to listen the small events
of your life when I say small events I
mean your business your marriage your
children all those big things all these
things are just a stepping stone so the
fear of failure
failure is bad enough fear is adding
spice to into presenter success happens
to you not because you desire it because
you own it
everybody desires it it comes only you
capable of it
thank you guys so much for watching
we're continuing in this series of the
volume 2 episode so I'd love to know
what you guys think and if there's
anybody you want to nominate for volume
2 let me know I'm also really curious to
figure out what did you learn from studs
to do today that had the biggest impact
on you and why what message did you take
that you're going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
leave it down the comments below and I'm
going to join in the discussion finally
I want to give a quick shout to Ronda
young Rhonda thank you so much for your
support in buying my books your one word
I really really really really appreciate
it so thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is let's love
I'll see you soon
if you want to suck TV never mind this
will play a major role Luigi
praise God effort unless on winning
election if you want to be near items
that are lucky fulfill faith god lot
effort maybe all of them but in what
proportion
so when you say faith obviously
something that you cannot do anything
about when you say luck again obviously
something that you cannot do anything
about when you say God again it's
something that you cannot do anything
about so only thing that's in your hands
is effort
so put your 100% into your effort what
happens happens physically so don't
leave proportions of your energy and
your capability to luck God faith all
these things that's not your business if
there is such a thing it will act your
business is only effort it's something
just do that effort has to be incisive
in the sense it should be focused
calibrate it simply if you make effort
it's foolish effort isn't it just labour
is not going to get you somewhere right
kind of action the right timing right
place all this is important isn't it so
for all these things to happen you need
perception and intelligence so that's
all you must do in your life constantly
looking for ways to enhance your
perception and your intelligence rest
will anyway happen
this is one thing that unfortunately
humanity is not doing they're trying to
become capable of something do not try
to become capable of something just
enhance your perception and intelligence
whatever comes your way right now let us
say it's like this you know this is
happening in the world all the time
everybody wants to become a dot not now
is 25 years ago it was so you want to
study means first thing is medicine if
you don't get a seat what's next
Engineering don't get a seat what max
then next thing like this so let's say
you became a doctor and let us say
everybody came to the yoga program and
they stopped going to a doctor at least
your visits to the doctor has come down
isn't it has it has it come down or not
for sure it's come down so business will
go down it will no more be a good
profession to go into because very few
doctors are becoming doctors because
they want to become doctors others are
becoming doctors because they think it's
lucrative you know isn't it so most
people are becoming doctors because they
think somebody's sickness is a lucrative
business it's a very I don't want to go
into other aspects it's quite disturbing
for me there are few doctors who really
want to be that they want to understand
the human system and they want to serve
in that direction that's great
suppose everybody became healthy you
don't want that isn't it if you don't
own that so do not try to put up a
recipe for your success success is only
when you are able to use yourself to
your full potential
it doesn't matter whether you become a
doctor or politician or a yogi or what
the hell you become is not the thing
success means you are living your life
to your full potential that's what
success means if that has to happen you
need perception and an active
intelligence how do I grow my
intelligence don't worry about that
right now the important thing is to
enhance your perception if you are able
to see life just the way it is
you have the necessary intelligence to
conduct it well if you are not able to
see life the way it is your intelligence
will work against you most intelligent
people on this planet are generally the
most miserable people on the planet this
is simply because they have an active
intelligence but no perception of life
so one thing one most important thing
that people have not worked at is to
enhance their perception they are trying
to broaden their mind that's not the
point that will only make you socially
successful not truly successful if you
want to be truly successful you must be
able to see everything just the way it
is without distortions if you can see
everything just the way it is life
becomes a play you can play joyfully you
can play it well for sure if you can
play it well
people will say you're successful you
should never think I want to be
successful don't ever think I want to be
successful just see how to make this
being in your full-fledged being people
will say one day oh he's successful he's
a great success you should not be
aspiring for success it's a miserable
way to structure your life you will
simply cause pain and suffering to
yourself and suffering to everybody
because your idea of success is sitting
on top of somebody's head isn't it yes
or no your idea of success is right now
everybody should be below you you must
be on the top this is your idea of
success this is not success this is
sickness so do not ever think of success
just see how to make this into your
full-fledged being this will find
expression if it finds good expression
people around you will say oh he is a
great success that's fine
people should recognize you're a success
you should not be thinking how to be
successful very wrong way to approach
life